one random thing i wanted to ask you
about because this that it kind of
fascinates me
is how many people in the industry have
to change their names
when they're first getting started or in
your case change their spelling
and i don't know was that a thing that
you really had to
discuss and work through in your own
mind or was it kind of just no big deal
no it wasn't no big deal and it's funny
you mention it because i did think about
this the other day on my own i i thought
gosh it
you know if it was if it was now i
probably wouldn't have done it um
it was it was part of i guess the
culture
back then this like old kind of
hollywood thinking where
um you know to to anglicize your name a
bit more
and or make it less complicated or less
of a mouthful and
and yes of course it is it is a mouthful
i spell it
differently to what it is actually you
know how it's actually
spelt but i kept thinking if everyone
can get past schwarzenegger and learn
how to say that then surely they can
learn how to say my name as well
um which is why i never i
just always rubbed me the wrong way to
change it to something completely
different which
was which was suggested um
so i kind of went for this phonetic
spelling
version um yeah
it's it it's definitely it was a it was
a cultural thing back then that's
something that i don't think that i
would
do now if i were to start now and
just and move forward